we've got a number which is apparently
so famous that it's up there on the
mathematical constants list up there
with PI and E and root 2 but this one
I've never heard of until recently and
apparently well they're pretty sure it's
irrational so I'm just going to give you
the first bit of it this is Feigenbaum
constant or one of the eigen Browns
constants there's another one if you
find references to it we're not going to
talk about the second one which has a
simple alpha there's a paper in I think
1970 order by Robert May about a
equation which I'm going to write down
which models population growth X so it's
traditional and this is going to be like
a population level and it's a word
modeling like how things breathe there
may be rabbits or frogs let's go with
rabbits because they breed like care
yeah rabbits it's going to have some
other variables in it this is what they
call the logistic map math is Oscar posh
word for a function you get an input and
output and it's mapping one value to
another one but what this does is it
predicts what the next year's population
is going to be for a community of
animals the first component here is the
next year population that means this one
here is the previous and so we're just
we're kind of counting populations
they're going to be between 0 & 1 like
empty dead population and a full
population and that's what this number
is as well so we've got like what we're
going to iterate this we're going to get
an answer and put it back in together
next year's thing and then the important
number here is this lambda it's like the
fertility so if this is high these
things are going to breed like like like
rabbits and if it's zero they're not
going to bring a tool and changing this
number is what the biologists were using
to sort of multiple different
populations if the previous population
is high you'd expect the neck want to be
I see you kind of multiplying by the
previous year's population but also if
it's too high they're going to run out
food so that's what you do one minus the
previous population so this is like the
breeding and this is like starvation
what's interesting is he you can just
put numbers into this so I'm going to
start with a population x1 of 1/2 so
remember this is going to use between 0
& 1 the population is heartful to start
with in fact you can start with anything
what's interesting is what happens over
a long time so we need to choose a
fertility I'm going to choose for this
particular example lambda the fertility
to be unknown it turns out you need to
be between 0 & 4 there are complicated
reasons for that which I'm not going to
go into right now so I'm going to choose
2.3 so they're about middle in our range
of fertility so this characterization
tells me the next year's population has
gone up I've got zero point five seven
five
so my populations increase they've got
enough fertility that the breeding is
happening well what's interesting though
is what happens over a long time but
yessiree we get 0.56
- oh yeah the populations drop so we've
clearly gone high enough that the
competition started kicking in and maybe
they can't sustain that high population
what's interesting though is if you you
if you wonder how is this going to
bounce
lots of times and actually typing this
in every time is extraordinarily tedious
although I know you're watching this for
exactly that reason so we can speed this
up and you can do it on any of these
cuttings because it has an iteration
function so I clear this and I've typed
2.3 times answer whatever the previous
answer Wars is going to turn up there
and then 1 minus answer and then either
I never have to type anything in again
this is my idea of mass so next year I'm
not going to write it down anymore but
next year x4 get point five six six oh
it's gone up and if I keep pressing
equals I'm not going to read them out
anymore but keep an eye on what's
happening just going to keep pressing
equals two point five six four nine four
point five six five point five six five
one nine point five six five two two
point five six five two two point five
six five two two point five six five two
two okay you know what's going to happen
with it it looks like actually and this
is believable right sometimes
populations stabilize and this is good
because this is the real world being
described by a simple equation this is
not all that exciting asked to say but
but at least I can do this calculation
repeatedly I can bash the burners many
times are like and it it's not changing
anymore it's genuinely doing the
calculation but it's giving the same
answer is what they call a fixed point
of the iteration so the rabbits are
breeding but they're also dying and
they're dying and breeding at the same
rate that something's balanced and this
is good because the biologists needed a
simple way of modeling real populations
and real populations do you balance out
eventually what's nice about is this map
of this function or this equation is it
also manages to capture some more
complicated behavior which is what
happened to be change our lambda number
which is only what we should do now I
won't write all the calculations but I
can show you on my calculator what
happens if you change lambda I'm going
to do a lower fertility and I'm going to
do this quickly because I think you
might be able to predict what happens if
we have
fertile rabbits so I'm actually going to
reset my population to be a half I'm
going to be 0.5 and press equals and
store that as a previous answer I'm just
going to type in now a pot will do a
lambda of you want to pick a lambda
between 0 and 1 Brady 0.65 we can't have
0.65 I'll do point six five so we
started a half after one year we have a
relation to point one six two five your
rivers dying but if I keep pressing it
obviously I can now just keep pressing
it to see what happened point zero eight
point zero five point zero three is it
not looking good I'm just going to go
for it now point zero zero zero nine
point zero zero zero six eventually my
calculator is going to say let's stop
pressing equals they're all dead perfect
I'm now at zero and maybe it's not quite
zero good it's off the end of the
accuracy I care about the road yeah well
again useful to us to the Heartless
biologists to model sometimes
populations go out what happens in the
wall though is that sometimes probably
actors die and sometimes they're stable
and sometimes they do funky things and
and it kind of surprises the kids get
funky things because one funky thing if
I pick a higher fertility so I'm going
to set up my population to be a half 0.5
equals that's the first answer gone in
and then I'm going to use lambdas three
point two times so clearly three point
two times previous population times 1
minus previous population and this time
we started at half after one year we've
got point eight populations gone up no
big surprise so it's all Revit next year
well there's lots of them now so you
know their competition kicks in they
steer point five one it's gotten way
back down to almost where we started
well too many rabbits you know there's
not enough grass or the foxes are like
whoa hey rabbit season and they've ate I
realize we're not counting foxes in this
thing but somehow this is capturing
behavior the Popular's go up and then
the class had got suddenly if there's
too many if I press equals again we're
at point seven nine it's gone back up
again definitely feels like we've got a
bit of a bouncy behavior and it's
believable where if I keep pressing
equals point five one point seven nine
point five one point seven nine in fact
I'm going to press it a few times it
might like take a bit of catching up a
bit if I slow down in a moment point
five one three zero four points
seven nine nine four six point five one
three zero four point seven nine nine
four six it's not changing except it's
changing every year but it's not
changing between these two values
and so it's stabilized we've got what
they call a fixed point but it's not
just one six point we have a two cycle
yo-yo yeah exactly and if you do a graph
and you see it bounce up and down and it
might be interesting to draw some graphs
for this in a moment because if I
thought Julia graph the first behavior
we had was with rabbits doing this
stabilizing and then the next day ahead
you have is rather dying and then we've
just seen something else can happen and
it happens out there in the real world
if you start somewhere and it sort of
bounces up here and down and then it but
doesn't stabilize ever it keeps bouncing
like this now the reason this map is
being if this function is being used is
it is capturing even more complicated
behaviors and just delights and deaths
we've got life but hard calculations are
too many rabbits for they kind of die
off but next year there's loads of space
for them so they grow again under the
ground I'm going to pick lambda to be
this is it a carefully chosen value I'm
going to pick it to be 3.5 let's try
that one get the population to be 1/2
3.5 is lambda multiplied by the previous
population multiplied by 1 minus
previous calculation this kind of goes
up to point n 875 0.38 0.82 0.5 0 wait
these are all different I'm just going
to keep pressing it but it's definitely
not settling down I'll show you the show
what's happening on the screen we've got
0.5 0.8 7.3 eight point eight two point
five point eight seven point three eight
point eight two actually is cycling but
it's not - it's not full and so if I
drew a graph of this one this time it's
going sort of down up down down a bit
further up a bit further and then down
up down bit further up a bit further so
actually we've got a we've got a four
cycle at this point like doing this on a
calculator it becomes a bit of a waste
of time but what the biologists were
doing where the computer was saying okay
even complicated behavior like a four
year cycle of populations can be modeled
by this we still just this one parameter
this one fertility thing and that
surprise them what they didn't know was
about to happen
what happens if you go above 3.5 because
no one ever did because it looked like
it didn't do anything useful if you
changed Landers beyond roughly three
point five nine something strange
happens which we should try and see on a
picture the little graph graph here this
is going to be this time is not time
this is going to be the lambda axis so
I'm going to capture with different
values of lambda the fertility on this
axis this is still going to be
population between zero and one I'm
going to mark this at four and this is
one so this is the behavior after it's
settled down so between 0 and 1 it turns
out if you picked lambda between 0 and 1
eventually things die as you as you
nicely exemplified you killed all the
rabbits because they're not fertile
enough so after you press equals
thousands of times we're going to plot
what happens so this is this is the
Death Zone yet let me which writes death
here because over time the population
stabilizes as a zero
you chose point six something and it was
in the desert so this is kind of your
point here when we did it earlier we
chose two point three here which is not
about here but it's stabilized to be
about point five six language point five
six five when we do it so it's kind of
just over hot so there's a mark on our
graph here and if you do this and you
could plot this on a spreadsheet if you
want to do you see that the stability
changes in this sort of pattern and the
different values that fertility give you
different stable populations interesting
ly it sort of levels off at about
two-thirds it looks like you can't have
a stable population that's fuller than
that according to this model but you've
already seen that something interesting
happens we tried three point two I think
earlier so three point two gave us a two
cycle which means over a long time we're
going to have two marks on this graph
and so I'm just going to sort of
estimate then about here and here and
the graph if you plot it bifurcates
which is a posh way of saying is Forks
like they call it a pitchfork
bifurcation so this is we've got dead
we've got stable and then from about
three we get two cycle but we will have
also seen that at three point five is
settled into a four cycle so then you
can kind of guess what's going to happen
if I put the four and they happen to be
around here you can see that somewhere
is blitz and it by four case again with
Forks again but the posh word
this is the period of these cycles this
is a one cycle because it's got one
value this is a two cycle experience too
and then it goes to four and the call
that's a period doubling thing what's
intriguing is that by picking certain
values of lungo you can get any periods
you want as long if it's a power of two
because it doubles every time so if you
want a sixteen cycle there is a value of
lambda I'll let you go and find it it's
not much higher than what we used at
three point five because coming out and
look at this graph again the graph
doubles again and again and again and
again and quicker and quicker and
quicker so a tiny change in this lambda
gives you a new branch and it gets
insane it gets like get so you can't
make any change even to the accuracy of
your calculator and expect to notice a
difference but massively different
behavior is happening and if you
recognize this sort of thing this is
this was being studied before the word
chaos was used but we now understand
technically the word chaos a partridge
made mess it means technically something
which is really sensitive to initial
conditions so this is a good example a
tiny change in our lambda gave you
massively different behavior and from a
modeling point of view for rabbits this
starts getting useful because it becomes
very hard to predict what's going to
happen with a certain value of lambda
but there is a final twist before I get
to a final twist which is what happens
that graph further to the right
Michell Feigenbaum got involved in this
at this point in the 70s and he was
looking at this thinking this is
surprising that a simple function does
an interesting thing like this and he
starts to study how quickly this
doubling happened so that that took a
little gap and this took a shorter gap
and this takes a shorter gap again
because it's going quicker and quicker
I think Toby it is interesting to know
if this is a sort of regular scaling
thing he didn't think it would be
because it's doing crazy stuff but he
started dividing one of these these
regions so like if you divide that width
by that width and then that one by the
previous one just to see the ratio and
it got this number Feigenbaum constant
is called now four point six six nine
now in itself is quite amazing this has
a nice regular behavior what it's saying
is that this gap is about 4 0.6 times
smaller than the previous gap
so the period doubling is getting
quicker and quicker it's a geometric
series in fact if you multiply that by
4.6 decline you roughly get this one and
if you keep going he managed to prove
that this is the ratio it's tending
towards but he doesn't know what this
number is and still no one knows
actually what this number is we don't we
don't have a closed form of explaining
what this number is
what is genuinely shocking is that he
then looks at some other equations
forget biology now he just looked at
other quadratic equations if you haven't
spotted already I'm just gonna point it
out this equation here is a quadratic
because it has an x times an x he looked
at all sorts of other functions all of
them having a single sort of hump and
this is a quadratic map with a single
hump and he found that every function he
looked at not only exhibited this period
doubling if you started fiddling with
the parameter but it also scaled with
that number and it turns out now this is
called Feigenbaum constant because every
uni-modal map from quadratic map scales
like this and no one knows what this
number is or why things are behaving
like this but it seems to describe a
whole raft of things which no one had
ever looked at before and there was this
concept of universality that even
different situations are still captured
by this number so I'm going to recreate
the diagram we had earlier on paper it's
going to start out here so that we've
got our lambda along here and this
little red dot which is now tracking
question we're in the dead zone here
this is where population is dead but
after warning see it spikes up so this
is a stable population now and it's
going to go all the way to three before
it does you can you remember what
happens it's going to split bifurcate at
three so that's our two cycles and then
I told you that it does something
roundabout three points for a little bit
after to show you that now it's again
that's our second bifurcation but you
know it's going to get quicker and
quicker this is what Feigenbaum found so
after this it's going to period double
very very very quickly but actually at a
point which is about three point five
nine it's not very far away you can
prove the period doubling must stop at
that point because that will be likely
is the if you add a geometric series up
to infinity there's there's a limit and
so the prediction doesn't tell you what
happens after that point but you can see
it we can go beyond infinity right now
so at 3.6 the period doubling is going
to stop and something else is going to
take over and just a little watchlist so
there's no strange behaviors it's nice
and simple and then crazy and laughing
this is a good example of chaos as well
I'm going to zoom in on that region so
here's the two cycle and has spread
again to a four cycle and then eight and
sixteen and then right there we've gone
in what we call the uncensored chaos and
there's a technical term chaos meaning
really sensitive but it's it's almost
beautiful there's weird structure
happening here this is not a glitch in
my software and yet it looks like the
most of its spitting out random so these
are the populations every time there was
equal its creating a dot just get
crazier than when you're right to spot
that the mandible set is involved with
it because this is a fractal if you zoom
in on stuff so i zoom in on this period
doubling bit you can see more period
doubling it is self-similar but then the
self-similarity thinks this will go a
bit crazy actually this is the
Mandelbrot set so you're only seeing one
dimension of it the Mandelbrot set as
you may know is all about using complex
numbers we need two dimensional numbers
if you just looked at the central line
of the Mandelbrot set and plotted what
the point to do when you do the
iteration this is what you see and
actually this was happening the same
time as Benoit Mandelbrot was
discovering about the beginnings of
fractals and catch so this is all tied
together what's lovely about is that
even in chaos you get order turning up
so this here is a three cycle it's going
crazy over here and then suddenly it
settles down to stable behaviour three
cycle in fact it doubles to a get six
and then you get well but then it goes
back to chaos again and nobody expected
this behavior to happen from a really
simple equation it's just the same
equation we've been using all along and
it was the beginning of chaos theory
what they call non-linear dynamics now
we're with simple deterministic
equations have very unpredictable
results and one massive application for
it is if you want a computer to generate
a random number you can't like you tell
the computer to pick something random
and it goes seven no that doesn't have a
function like we do although we always
pick seven it seems but if you wanted a
computer to spit out a random number you
have to pretend you have to tell you
what to do because this computer but
what you could do is tell it to use this
function
press equals a few times near the end of
our diagram and it would spit out a
number which appears to be random they
call them feud a rounded numbers but
this formula was one of the first ones
they ever used to make what we now call
pseudo-random numbers if you've enjoyed
this video you might be the sort of
person who would like the great courses
Plus this is a huge on-demand video
library starring the best lecturers and
teachers from around the world joining
up gives you unlimited access to this
vast library of really in-depth meaty
courses about all sorts of things
including some brilliant ones about
mathematics and for example this one all
about fractals
but whatever your passion or interest
the great courses plus is going to have
something probably many things up your
alley
just lately I've been watching this
particular video all about the early
days of aviation because well I love
anything to do with plane to have a look
go to the great course of class comm
slash numberphile the links are on the
screen and there's also a link in the
video description you can just click on
using the link we'll give you a free
one-month trial with total access to the
whole archive so why not give them a
look at the way of showing a bit of
support for numberphile but also a
chance to do some serious Bennion
learning and d-boy hello Audrey you got
you heard about chaos and so I'll be
expecting it it's a nice book come on as
we go okay